зайди до євромайдану
україна зрубала ви лайка їсти рибалка в
розвитку демократії за 2 руки після
революції влади країна піднялася на 20
позицій на 38 та місяці тут 120 давид та
держав у польщі в room- набряки спливаючи
на політиці на вище питча свого рифу
all і письмових означає фонді бордерс
моно таким членом
україна вибору дала вона ж грузію якоб
осідають рукави місяці у свиті
хоче значно раніше стала на шлях
євроінтеграції
Росія ж заливним демократії в 2
менше хіба на них україна то грузії
то вбиваючи 83 місяці у свиті в українській
економіці не видно на вид політики та
прориву на сталося економічному daewoo
за skoda в конфлікт на сході України
корупції палив олігархічних то
колоди політику так вже експерти фонду
бартер sman означає, що щур в Росії
тому європа значилося на економічному
розвитку всю опус троянську в районі
серед іншого та на Україні на литках
черевань економіки змогла продумати
строго тієї грузія росія заливним
економічного розвитку на шістдесят
п'ятому місці україна
аж на 70 третьому закіні експерта пакла
дають надію на українську граматично
сусп листя найвиднішого закласти диво
ти знову але політики в для втирання
економічних реформ тим часом
активність граматику з тим українці у
складний укладати а у позитиву в ту
барвисті краю на хп astra дитячий
регіону
як ефект азербайджан казахстан чарусі
я означає експерти фонду бертільсона
щоб він і батоги по волині рудому влада
цифра встановила жорсткий шипр і душу в
цієї свободи слова то зборі